تسريح بالالاف شمله سته في المئه من قوتها
العامله في انحاء العالم بهذا تنضمت
الشركه الاوملي جوجل الى قائمه بدا تطول
من شركات التكنولوجيا التي اعلنت مؤخرا
خطوات مماثله وفق تعميم من مديرها
التنفيذي سوندار بيشاي فقد وسعت جوجل
اعمالها بشكل سريع خلال الرائحه كورونا
حين تزايد الطلب على الخدمات الالكترونيه
لكن عمليه التوظيف تلك استندات الى واقع
اقتصاديا مختلفا عن ما تواجهه شركه من
تحديات اليوم
جدا وجميعها الى تعيينات المبالغ فيها حتى
بعد عمليات التسريح ما زالت هذه المؤسسات
اكبر من ما كانت عليه قبل عده سنوات
وتاتي هذه الخطوه في وقت تتجه فيه انظار
الشركه نحو تكنولوجيا جديده تعتمد على
ذكاء الصناعي وسط منافسه متصاعده لها من
شركه مايكروسوفت في هذا المجال
لكن التسريحات تاتي ايضا وسط مخاوفا من
ركود اقتصادي وفي ظل تضخم ادى الى رفع
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي اسعر الفائده ووفق
الخبراء فقد ادى ذلك الى تقليص الاعلانات
على منصات التكنولوجيا والاستثمار في
اسهمها
يعني
ربما تدفع بالاقتصاد في الاتجاه الذي يسير
به باتجاه الدخول في الركود ولكن هي اخبار
جيده للشركه يعني اليوم بعد الاعلان عن
هذا الخبر ارتفع سهم همم جوجل همم حوالي
اربعه ونصف بالمئه خلال التعاملات الساعات
الاولى وفي نفس الوقت اعتقد ان التاثير
على مستوى العالم لن يمتد اكثر مما حدث
خلال الفتره الحاليه همم كل شركه وكل دوله
لها خ وتتعامل وفقا لظروفها الاقتصاديه مع
هذه الامور قبل جوجل اعلنت شركه
مايكروسوفت في الثامنه عشر من هذا الشهر
تصريحا نحوي خمسه في المئه من قوتها
العامله وفي اليوم نفسه اعلنت امازون
تصريحه واحده في المئه فقط من قوتها
العامله التي تبلغ مليونا ونصفا المليون
موظف لكن الرقم يعد الاكبر بين نظراتها في
قطاع تكنولوجيا وكانت وتر وفيسبوك ايضا
اعلنتا تصريحات مماثله
ووفقه موقعي لا يعصف واي اي شهد عام 2022
عمليات تصريحا في قطاع تكنولوجيا فقط 150
الفن مع توقعات بان يرتفع الرقم في عام
تؤثر عمليات تسريح هذه على حياه الموظفين
الذين فقدوا قوت يومهم لكن بالنسبه لجوجل
وغيرها من الشركات تعد هذه الخطوه تقليصا
لفائضا من الموظفين بعد ان فرضت رائحه
كورونا توسعا على شركات تكنولوجيا الكبرى
لسان ابو كويك الجزيره رستم فيجننيا